Kirk you weren't playing for the
championship but you could affect the
standings and you did just that how are
you feeling right now with this last few
games performances
I mean
I don't know I mean this game was just a
complete mess but this is what I was
striving for before the game I just
wanted to play a very cute chaotic
stressful game I just think uh I mean my
opponent basically uh
didn't play so good under a lot of
stress which is understandable because
he was obviously fighting for first
place and doesn't want to lose with
white
a stressful game I don't think I've ever
heard that before you were running for a
stressful game that's very interesting
because for both sides of course but
especially for him because he was
playing with so much pressure on his
shoulders that's a very intriguing
strategy how did you come up to that
with that idea I mean I I think I've
been on the receiving end of that a
couple of times in my life but um that's
why I chose this uh dubious open
Sicilian line for black I didn't know
the lines so well but even if the
position goes bad it's very hard for
white to keep everything under control
in these types of games the evaluations
change a lot and it's a very complicated
position and another thing that you were
doing you were putting a lot of pressure
on your opponent's clock early on you're
playing fast even though you said that
you didn't know the opening but you were
still playing fast confident chess tell
us a bit about when you felt you're
starting to gain the advantage you're
starting to take over yeah so first of
all I played uh fast so I could put them
under more stress on the clock because
of course even though he knows he's much
better in that position it's very hard
to find the exact way for white to
improve his position and also it's not
pleasant when the opponent's worst they
keep making aggressive moves quickly I
thought I was better when he allowed
Bishop E2 I think he missed Bishop E2
yes yes that's what we thought as well
uh Bishop to E2 was a big turnover
turn around for this game maybe F5 this
was an interesting move did you consider
this move at all didn't even consider it
probably my opponent didn't either I
thought he was going to give the
exchange but not like that like Rook G1
maybe and then G5 something like that
yeah something like this or even G5 in
the first position one of those two
moves I I didn't think of F5 at all F5
is so counter-intuitive because you hang
the g-pawn and The Rook exactly yeah wow
yeah and I I mean it's not probably the
best move and it still remains
complicated uh but I thought it's an
interesting way to try to open up and
make space for his pawns to be pushed
right yeah c66 things of that nature
correct
big game big win for you congratulations
it's all important to perform well in
this type of stressful situation so
that's something that our viewers can
definitely take away from this one
congratulations and we'll see you
perhaps next year thank you
our congratulations as well Kirk
definitely uh